In this video, I want to show you how to
organize your panels in DreamFlow to
create the most efficient workspace for
your needs. Now, this idea is actually
central to our design philosophy of
Dreamflow itself because we believe that
every modern developer should have three
types of tools or surfaces readily
available. A code editor, a visual
interface, and an AI prompt for an AI
agent. Now, depending on the task and
your preferences, you may want to
interact directly with the code or work
with a visual properties panel or select
widgets from your app itself to be able
to change them or to chat with an AI
agent to make the changes itself. So, we
designed Dreamflow not only to provide
these three surfaces, but also to give
you the freedom to show and hide them
based on what you're working on. So,
let's jump in and check this out. So
when you jump into DreamFlow, you're
going to see something like this
interface right here. Now there are two
main ways to show and hide different
surfaces depending on what you need. So
the first way is up here with these
three options. So if I toggle this one,
this will show this module or widget
tree option over here. Now, if you have
other modules open like a Firebase or a
Superbase or your assets panel right
here, this will collapse that as well.
But most often, you're going to have
this widget tree panel open. Okay. The
second one is your properties panel. So,
this is contextual. So, whatever widget
you have selected, you'll see the
properties of that widget populate here.
And then finally, this third option, you
have your AI agent panel. Now to show or
hide these of course you can just click
these on or off. We also have shortcut
keys. So you have option two, three and
four to open and close these. So that's
the first way. The second way is to open
and close them with options within the
panel itself. So you've got these X
marks right here just as you would
expect. But also when they're closed you
can see that you've got these bars right
here that you can just click to open
them just like that. So if you want one
or two or all three open, you can just
toggle them however you want. Okay. So
those are the sort of two main ways to
manage your panels. But in this code
view right here, there's some additional
options you have. So right now I'm just
going to keep everything collapsed like
that. And I want to open up code view
right here. And you'll probably see
something like this. So you'll have your
files and folders, your file explorer
view right here, and then you'll have
the actual code of whatever file you
have open on the right. Now, I find
myself most often wanting to see a
preview of the app and my code at once.
And that's where this split option comes
in right here. That is, it's split
between my code view over here on the
left and the preview over here. Now, if
you want your preview on the left and
your code on the right, that's what this
button is here for. And so, you can just
swap those. Now, most of the time, what
you're going to want is the preview and
the actual code that you're going to be
working on most of the time, and then
you just switch between files. So, that
is to say, you don't need this visual
space of your file explorer. So, you can
just close that up right there. And
then, if you want to change the space
between these, you can just pull those.
And that works on any of these files. So
maybe I want to have my agent open. So
I've got my preview, I've got my code,
and then I've got my agent. And you can
adjust the difference like that. Okay.
So that's your code view. But remember,
when you're in this nested code view, so
you can have your code here. You can
have your split view. You can have your
files open up just like that. Of course,
you can combine that with any of these
up here. So if I open it up like that,
now I have my widget tree. Let's scale
this down so it's not budging up against
the edges. You can change the size of
your widget tree like that. Now, of
course, I'm having trouble seeing my
code right here. So, I can collapse my
file tree right there. And that works
great. So, that's how to manage your
workspace. So, you can make it efficient
and tailor it to whatever needs and
development styles you have. Let us know
if you have any questions and you can
submit feedback right here. So, if
there's a bug or a feature request or if
there's another style of working that
you would like to see in DreamFlow, we'd
love to hear from you and we'll see you
in the next video.